bonsoir
tristan cas vidéo merci d'être avec nous
sur rt france 14 hauts responsables du
parlement chinois sanctionné donc
l'administration trump et le
président-élu baydan sont d'accord sur
le sujet une fois n'est pas coutume est
ce le signe d'une probable continuité
dans la confrontation avec pékin oui je
crois qu'il n'y aura pas de différence
entre fondamentalement entre
l'administration d'haydn et
l'administration trump dans les rapports
chinois américains il faut dire que de
toute façon les américains ont toujours
été extrêmement protectionnistes c'était
le cas de donald trump s'asseoir là cas
de joe biden et en plus de ça son
nouveau secrétaire son nouveau ministre
des affaires étrangères anthony blinken
a dit très clairement qu'il était en
contravention totale avec la chine alors
la chine qui elle s'indigne un parle
d'ingérence et comme et des contre
mesures fermes est forte les rapports
sino-américains comment peuvent-ils
évoluer dans ce cas de figure
alors on a l'impression qu'il ya
vraiment des tensions qui grandissent
chaque jour entre les chinois et les
américains c'est vrai que pai de
d'antoni week-end remette de l'huile sur
le feu on a l'impression de réellement
tes rapports qui se détériore chaque
mois chaque jour et ça va aller en
empirant j'ai l'impression avec cette
nouvelle administration
alors revenons en maintenant à joe biden
et notamment la clis du coronavirus à le
président élu prévient sans action du
congrès les américains subiront un
retard voire un arrêt de la vaccination
une déclaration pour créer un choc
oui alors là il ya vraiment deux
discours complètement différent d'à côté
trump qui se félicite de l'avancée des
vaccins et c'est vrai que les vaccins
arrivent très vite et il nous l'avait
dit juste avant la campagne puis d'un
côté un bail donne qui a un discours
beaucoup plus sombre on a l'impression
sur 7 sur cette épidémie qui il est vrai
de toute façon fait de plus dans plus de
ravages aux états unis les cas de cause
on grandit on grandit de manière assez
exponentielle durant les dernières
semaines tout principalement d'ailleurs
à cause de la fête de thanksgiving qui a
augmenté d infection est donc là on a
vraiment deux manières de voir c'est à
dire d'un côté la positivité de naître
avec donc les vaccins qui arrivent et
qui promettent une fin de l'épidémie
et puis de l'autre côté un bail dunn qui
nous dit qu'on en est encore très loin
et qu'il va avoir vraiment et ce soit ça
c'était ses mots hier tom winter
c'est à dire une univers très sombre à
quelques minutes d'intervalle le
président trump sortant lui annoncer
qu'il prioriser la livraison des vaccins
pour passer avant les autres pays alors
il reste dans son rôle en donald trump
américaine s'intéresse très offensive
est ce que c'est une parole de
communication
on est toujours tenté de dire que c'est
une parole de communication donald trump
c'est à dire qu'il ne peut pas de toute
façon se substituer à la vie de la f10
et qui n'a pas encore de re donner son
avis sur ses vaccins puisque les vaccins
des données ne sont pas encore
disponibles avec des live qui devrait
rendre son avis donc vers la fin
décembre
ça voudrait dire que la vaccination
pourrait commencer très tôt en début de
l'année prochaine
maintenant il est vrai que donald trump
finalement avait raison - avant de la
revendre élections le vaccin arrivait il
arrive à grands pas et il est là
vraiment c'est juste une question de
semaines pour que les américains
puissent se faire vacciner
on en a beaucoup parlé anthony fochi
avec lequel voilà c'était pas la grande
entente
sur les derniers mois avec donald trump
confirmé dans son rôle de conseiller sur
le co vide alors que précisément vous
l'avez rappelé les etats-unis sont
confrontés à une hausse très importante
des cars notamment après les fêtes de
thanksgiving c'est une bonne chose
son vous cette cette confirmation oui
alors faut-il a été très compétents dans
la dans la gérance du ducourneau virus
est quelqu'un de très compétent qui a
été là qui est là aux états unis que les
américains connaissent depuis l'épidémie
du sida c'est quelqu'un qui était déjà
là au début de l'épidémie de sida en
ce qui est très important c'est une
hotte est là c'est que la donne a nommé
un nouveau ministre de la santé qui est
en fait un ministre de la santé qui est
plutôt du côté progressiste de notes de
l'aide d'une parti démocrate
xavier becerra c'est quelqu'un qui est
pour limiter le profit des compagnies
pharmaceutiques c'est aussi quelqu'un
qui pour le medicare forum qui était la
grande mesure de bernie sanders
donc tout ça on a envie de se dire ça
marche ça fonctionne dans la bonne
direction
maintenant j'ai envie de dire que
l'épidémie aura des conséquences
sociales et économiques qui sont
absolument énorme je vous entendez
parler tout à l'heure avec la
représentante du gilet jaune c'est à
dire que ici aux etats-unis en effet
comme vous l'avez dit il n'y a pas de
système de santé de 6ème santé du
système social où les gens se sentent
supporter sentent soutenus lorsqu'ils
perdent leur travail et leur assurance
santé
cela veut dire que joe biden va
probablement débuter son mandat avec une
forme de gros boulet à la jambe
josé familièrement et alors il y aura il
y aura il y aura une épidémie qui sera
énorme c'était vraiment encore une fois
les canaris n'arrête pas de s'accroître
et puis en plus de sa 15 % peut-être de
chômeurs 15 millions d'américains qui ne
peuvent plus payer leur loyer
donc on est vraiment dans un pays qui a
beaucoup de difficultés en ce moment et
et joe biden commence à président en ce
moment sous comme il l'a dit dans un
hiver très rude
alors ce mardi c'est un jour important
puisque tous les états on disait tout à
l'heure américains devront savoir
certifier leurs résultats électoraux au
moins fermé la porte à toute nouvelle
contestation
ça y est c'est définitif c'est une
sortie donc pour donald trump et une
élection pour radio by dane oui alors je
crois que l'élection est tout à fait
confiant
hayden gagne de vote populaire depuis 2
7 millions de votes
c'est une des victoires des plus grandes
de l'histoire des états unis
et il gagne dans certains états clés à
aa avec une très petite avance un
finalement mais j'ai envie de dire que
rien n'est fini pour donald trump et
même que peut-être tout commence pour
lui puisque l'on entend déjà dire que le
jour de l'inauguration de joe biden
donald trump a décidé de contenir un
rallye un meeting avec ses supporters
qui concurrencera la télé donc
l'inauguration de joe biden donc je
crois que vraiment dans les quatre
prochaines années dont la trame sera
encore tout à fait présent même s'il
n'est plus président pour contrebalancer
vraiment toutes les initiatives de joe
biden encore quelques surprises si on
est d'incompris merci tristan cabello je
rappelle que vous êtes donc maître de
conférences en civilisation américaine à
la john hopkins university merci à vous